thanks uh Yasser we are here with the
defending Champion yanashi staff Duda
after a dominant first day two and a
half out of three or five points with
um the two for a victory two points for
a victory one for a draw scoring system
congratulations tell us a bit about your
initial feelings about this day one yeah
thank you yeah it's been for sure really
a good day for me
um yeah I don't think I could really
expect more from the games so
um yeah I'm very positive to you know
start
um well in Warsaw and you really started
strong with a big victory against Anish
take us through this game it felt like
Anish came swinging he was really
looking for a fight I mean he's like uh
a bit sadistic and he's playing this G6
you know all the time against me
um
you know but in Rapid like all the time
G6 and why didn't he televised me with
his grandified and I'm like switching
lines and all the time and
um yeah I mean this time I mean I have
again played this F34 but just together
again without any you know Fury that was
the point but um I don't think
I I don't think this position is like uh
you know maybe I'm not worse but I can
be possibly better in here because
like uh black doesn't have a knight so
now his pieces are you know I have more
space yeah yeah I mean and he's not
struggling with space so but perhaps
still struggling with the C8 Bishop a
little bit yeah I mean also like Knight
H5 also Knight D7 at some point was
possible I think like or I mean it's
yeah here or even I mean you know
yeah I mean I mean I mean everything
everything is kind of okay for him when
did you feel like he started going
astray yeah I didn't like B5 actually I
had missed it so I was very very
unpleasant moment when he played B5
first second but then I realized that
after the next B5 Rook B8 he probably
and
assumption probably forgot about the A4
inclusion because if I play nhc3 Then he
has Bishop A6 yeah and like uh it's good
for actually winning here for black yeah
but after A4 I6 I mean he doesn't have
an 86 core Norwich Basics and now you
actually Force the trade of the bishop
for the Knight which is probably good
for you yeah I was also considering
Queen C2 instead of this queen A2 to
give up the exchange in this version and
Bishop takes a one Rook X1 F5
uh I sort of like my position but it
couldn't quite you know
um
and see what to do here because black is
very active also like Queen F6 heavy and
there are some tricks like Bishop H3 for
example in some positions like uh I
don't know really one
uh let's take okay Knight takes well
okay sure yeah but I was considering
contacts actually maybe he can also
start with Queen F6 yeah and yeah yeah
that's very nice yeah yeah you cannot
take because now you lose yeah it's the
idea that you have to always to be heard
about him this is white so the opening
of the file very cool very cool Motif
and uh yeah and actually I I sort of
like my queen on A1 but um
yeah I mean I mean it was uh
it was just you know like even only just
just Uncle benoni game basically so yeah
uh here I thought I mean because I uh
added I wasn't so sure I mean can we
move a little bit yeah because this
position is like very very weird uh here
of course he of course started fishing
for repetition yeah with Bishop
defibration Basics I I didn't allow him
to do that I mean I I didn't play r2d1
back and
um yeah and this position is very very
weird actually I mean 1993 okay looks
logical yet to play the 19 before
another one I thought F5 is very
interesting actually for him and EF and
Ani before yeah Rook takes A5 Queen B1
is initial I think but um that makes
sense and yeah because Ruby is also on
the agenda yeah and he can really move
his knife
yeah but night before and I mean this is
just unclear position
I mean of course this F5 is a bit loose
I mean his King is a bit loose but um
yeah probably has to do it yeah yeah he
was considering it but um yeah it's
difficult you have to you know pick
something and it's difficult sometimes
you have to decide yeah one option and
after and here actually I was kind of
liking my position but um
um
yeah I thought because here I wanted to
like play G4 Bishop D2 Bishop C3 and
basically win the final F6 or at least
you know uh make him you know different
uh despawn all the time not allowing any
active uh play but um I think yeah but
that's definitely right yeah but I uh
like sort of didn't see I mean it's a
related Knight C2 because it's um
I mean here at least he has this like
you know uh this queen Aid move I have
to move back yeah and here it's like
um it's just unclear yeah I think I mean
okay
but you know in uh when you have two
minutes yeah it's like a completely
different story yeah anyone's game
almost and here I really like the idea I
really like like the idea of training in
diet that's why I played from C3 with
the idea of 9ito but I also sort of
forgot about this queen D1 A4
um yeah it was it was strong for him
because after 92 there is A3
and uh
it's annoying actually yeah because the
spawn is suddenly very dangerous yeah
becoming becoming dangerous yeah that
was his best chance and you know maybe
even more than quality for for black he
didn't find it then he took over and
very nicely executed the end game
Advantage
um congratulations one of the things
that we really saw was the support and
energy coming from the crowd here in
Warsaw did you feel that as well after
your second game against the arc
everybody started applauding we don't
see this very often in chess right yeah
it's like all tradition I would say
um yeah it's very nice especially when
you win the game not lose
um yeah I mean what can I add do you
feel like you have a home court
advantage compared to all these other
players
I
kind of don't remember I'm playing in
North also so
um
yeah but I like the venue here and yeah
I mean you know I said once as I said in
in college I think yeah once you
you know have a good tournament then
in some place and you're always like or
estimated so yeah yeah it's the case for
me I think well there's definitely the
good history following you in this venue
congratulations for a good first day and
we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Christian congratulations